[Music]
hey guys before the video starts i just
want to thank you a lot for showing so
much support to the channel
and since you've boosted the channel a
lot i want to show some love back to you
guys
7 50 amazon gift cards all you have to
do to enter the giveaways be a
subscriber like and comment the video
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about dany's death as well as
various jokes on taking her
a question which was answered at the end
of the finale but most of the fans
missed it
and what does that mean for dany alright
in disappointing serious finale john
founds himself with no choice but to
kill danny the madqueen
influenced by destruction of king's
landing but also by tyrone lannister who
convinced him that his family will never
be safe
as long as dany lives even imprisoned
tyrion once again talks his way out
jon snow visits him in his cell tyrion
talks about his own sins before getting
around to discussing their queen since
and how destructive and bad for the
world she is
in the end it comes back to jon being a
man of the watch
he is the shield that protects the
realms of men and right now dany is
making frightening plans
tyrion slowly gets inside jon's head and
convinces him he's got to kill her
not only to save him but to save himself
and his family because sansa will never
bend the knee to their queen
much like cersei didn't and we know what
happened to search senior city
the same will happen to sansa manor
fellas then he announced to her army
sitwood earlier
when giving them a speech at the end jon
chooses his sisters over dany
as he walks towards the throne room he
is stopped by dragon who eventually lets
him pass through
because he knows him he's a targaryen
he's a family he's safe for dany or so
he thought
inside the throne room denny sees the
unthrone almost exactly as it was in her
vision in the house of the undying
only it's a bit more damage with snow
and ashes falling on the armed throne
yes it was a literal vision not a
metaphor
as the queen danny targaryen is
surveying the broke throne room in the
red cape where the iron throne is
she approached the seat forged by aegon
the conqueror and his dragon valerian
and black dread
she lightly ran her fingers on one of
the many swords melted into the seat
and turned as if she is to sit upon it
then she noticed john egan targaryen
snow watching from the doorway
she rules the seven kingdoms but not for
long because there comes this third
betrayal then his last one
the betrayal for love jon had just
visited tyrion lannister who was being
held captive for treason
and tyrion did his best to convince jon
that dany was the wrong person to sit on
the arm throne
and the john sisters will never be safe
because they would never bend the knee
nor would john himself because he's the
biggest threat to her claim
john already realized dany is this mad
queen in episode 5 when she destroyed
the entire king's landing
and killed hundreds of thousands of
innocent and he knows vanerfell and
sansa will never be safe as long as
danny rules
but still he gives her one last chance
in the throne room
john angrily recalls how grey worm and
his and solid were killing surrender
lannister soldiers on the streets
and then he did not care telling john
the man made their choice to follow
cersei and their punishment was death
he gave dany one last chance to see if
she realizes what she has done to king's
landing is a huge crime
and must not happen again but then he
tries to justify her actions
additionally she says that's exactly
what will happen to the rest of westeros
and world
because the will must be broken a new
better world must be formed
she then starts telling jon how he and
she would then break the wheel
and everyone who would not bend the knee
would suffer the same punishment as
king's landing
pretty much confirming tyrion's words to
john if you don't kill her you know she
will kill your sister sansa and destroy
winterfell
who will not bend the knee and when john
heard this he knew what he had to do
he cannot allow dany to kill his sisters
or burn down the north
as jean pledges his loyalty to her the
two embraced and kissed
janju is dagger and step danny in the
heart killing her instantly
in my opinion den is the biggest victim
of the season 8 bad writing
it's not danny becoming the mid queen
that upsets me it's the progression
i'm glad it's not just us fans who are
saying the final season sucked
but it's also the actors who are
admitting their 10 year long character
making should have had better ending
among many the most notable ones or
should i say the loudest one are actors
who play jaime lannister where is john
and dany
anyways joe having a connection with his
mother came to the scene and it was a
heartbreaking moment
drogon lost everything his brothers and
now mother
his cry for his fallen mother was just
painful jogo nudges her tries to wake
her and he breaks my heart
the following though i don't like one
bit jon had just killed his mother
and instead of burning him alive jogon
burns the armed throne
makes sense just as much as dany's
dothraki bloodriders not seeking revenge
over their killed queen
when it's their sacred duty instead of
killing jon and destroying the rest of
westeros they're peacefully leaving
westeros
i might check out that petition to
remake season 8 after all
drogon most definitely received the best
character development in this season
as most fans pointed out exercising
judgment when experiencing blighting
angering grief
destroying the symbol of power and the
very source of evil and choosing to
mourn in solitude
now brotherless and matterless instead
of burning jon and all of westeros
some people had questions about why the
dragons seem to suddenly have such
nuanced logical and metaphorical
judgment
but to be fair we have been told by
tyrion that dragons are more intelligent
than most men
but i have to be honest i did not think
they were this intelligent or was it
just bad writing
animes down throne was created by
dragonfire so i guess it was at least
poetic for it to be destroyed by the
same
although it could have been done much
better for example danny having it
melted by dragon
having destroyed one thing that made his
mother danny mad and evil
drogon gently lifted his mother by his
claws and flew away across the narrow
sea
one question remained where exactly did
drogon go with annie
sam answered that question in small
council towards the end of an episode
thanking bran as for an update of the
shogun's whereabouts late in the finale
sam says he was last spotted flying east
towards valenis
before braun cuts him off what this
means is that dany's fate is left up to
debate
she's dead and she might stay that way
but she might also get resurrected by
the red priest as kimara
who happens to be the same city jogen
was last spotted flying towards
in fact i think the showrunners wanted
to imply to us viewers that dany will
probably not stay dead for long why else
would they mention drogon flying towards
volantis
they could have had jerome flying
towards valyria where the targaryens
originate
this could have been possible
destination for them both viewing as
it's where the targaryens traditionally
live with their dragons
second they could have had jon flying
towards the deuteroke sea
drogon and his dragon siblings were born
in the tragic territory
and they could have had him flying back
to the place he feels his home
but they didn't they specifically
mentioned jerome flying is towards
volantis
so why volantis and what's in volantis
valente is often called old volantis and
the first daughter is a city in south
western essos
located at the mouth of the rhine on the
summer seas the oldest and proudest of
the nine free
cities it was founded as a colony of
valyria many centuries ago
and is a great port volantis was the
first of the free cities founded by the
valyrian freehold investor nesos
four centuries ago valyria was destroyed
in a single day by a massive volcanic
cataclysm
known as the doom and the empire
fractured without sensual leadership
valyria's surviving colonies were torn
apart in a period of chaotic civil wars
known as the century of blood aegon the
first targaryen the possessor of the
last three valyrian dragons in the world
ended that war and now beyond grand
attempts were made
to unite all of the free cities into a
new valyrian empire
in the present day valentines remains
one of the more powerful of the free
cities
and has the largest population out of
any of them although more than 80
percent of that population are slaves
the first time we have symbol andes was
in season 5.
as tyrion and varys were making their
way to a market they spot a red
priestess preaching to a crowd of slaves
who catches tyrion's eyes as he stops to
listen to her sermon
she preaches that the lord of light has
sent them a savior the dragon queen
danny targaryen who has been waging a
campaign against slavery in marine
it's not just a city where people love
and support dany but more importantly
volantis is home to kinmara
a red priestess who made the brief
appearance in season six to lend her
support to team dany
she made during lannister and various in
the great pyramid of marine
tirion asked her people to rally behind
annie to ask them to see her as their
protector and guardian
not a conqueror kinmara was happy to
assist tyrion
saying dany is the one who was promised
from the fire she was reborn to remake
the world
then he has been sent to lead the people
against the darkness in this war
and in the great war still to come
quinmar promised to spread the word
about khaleesi throughout essos
sauvignon that the followers of the lord
of light stand behind annie
including kinmara whose titles read
flame of truth
the light of wisdom and first servant of
the lord of light the high priestess of
the red temple of valenis
and is one of the highest ranking of
railr clerics
since she firmly believes that danny
targaryen is the prince that was
promised and the one who will make
this world a better place much like
melisandre believed in jon when she
resurrected him
could it be that then he will get
resurrected by kinmara we'll never get
an answer
but i think it's implied that this is
likely the case
if not they would not mention jerome
flying towards valence which we know is
basically the capital of the lord of
light religion
the place filled with red priests who
worship dany and most importantly that's
where dany's biggest supporter among the
red priests and also the most powerful
of them all
is kinmara i think this is the same how
they ended jon's story as well
john goes back to the wall and takes the
black even though there's no need for
the night's watch anymore
jon knows this and tells tyrion that
it's ridiculous that the order even
exists
because there's no need for them then in
the closing montage he wears black
but he also goes beyond the wall with
tormund ghost and bunch of wildlings
yes johnny is wearing black much like
dany's dead but it's implied that he's
not coming back to wall but is rather
staying beyond
just like how it's implied danny will
not stay dead for long
because the place jogon is taking her to
vallanis pretty much means dany will get
resurrected
jump becomes the king beyond the wall
and danny the queen of essos
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below
do you think drogon taking danny to
valencia means she will get resurrected
or do you think she remains dead and
drogon is staying here there just
randomly
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace